[Musique]
nikos aliagas la députée européenne de
la public elle a dit mme morano à votre
habitude à crespo mara
bonjour gino clap de fin du grand débat
2 millions de contributions on va enfin
savoir ce que veulent les français et en
quoi l'exécutif va les satisfaire ou non
vous avez hâte alors moi je vais vous
dire on sait très bien ce qu'attendent
les français on sait comment a commencé
cette crise par une taxation massive des
carburants par une hausse de la csg sur
les retraités par une désindexation des
retraites sur les retraités et les
français attendent qu emmanuel macron au
maquereau répare ses fautes
ce sont des fautes politiques majeurs
cafés les magasins pour réparer tout
simplement parce que quand on supprime
isf
et quand on matraque les petits
retraités de taxes eh bien il faut
comprendre que c'est ça qui a engendré
cette colère mais selon le relief la
droite et pour aussi un oui mais voyez
j'ai entendu monsieur darmanin que vous
avez qualifié comment tout à l'heure de
renégats dans laissez vous qu'il ait ses
propres convictions quand je pense
qu'ils osent se prétendent de la droite
populaire jamais la droite populaire ne
s'en seraient pris aux retraités que
nous avons toujours protégé et rezé et
préserver ce que nous demandons ce que
nous voulons c'est la réindexation des
retraités il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui
près de 9 millions de retraités ont
perdu en pouvoir d'achat sur un an
environ 400 euros dans la région a dit
mme morano la réindexation gérald
darmanin dit que ça pourrait coûter
jusqu'à 3 milliards
vous les trouvez où ces trois millions
puisque comme le gouvernement vous ne
souhaitez pas rétablir lisf qui rapporte
justement 3000
alors vous savez monsieur darmanin dans
l'interview qu'il a donné dimanche à la
question le gouvernement veut-il ré
indexer les petites retraites sur
l'inflation elle répond la question peut
être posée
mais il faut savoir donc quel est le
coût peut être posée je ne dis pas que
la question moi peut-être posé jeudi que
la question doit être imposé c'est à
dire qu'il faut ré indexer les retraités
sur l'inflation
c'est indispensable pour leur pouvoir
d'achat et moi je vais vous dire
la retraite c'est pas une allocation
c'est pas un don c'est un dû faut bien
comprendre c'est un du pur pour ces
personnes qui ont bossé toute leur vie
et qui ont droit à leur retraite mais
ces trois milliards voulait trouver
refuge et voudrait tabou chez nous nous
avons nous avons présenté un plan de
réduction des dépenses publiques de plus
de 20 milliards d'euros
puis moi je vais vous dire une chose
quand vous regardez le coût de la
politique migratoire dans notre pays
faut savoir que rien que l'accueil de ce
qu'on appelle les mineurs étrangers
arrivés en situation irrégulière de
notre pays
ce qu'on appelle les mineurs non
accompagnés en politiquement correct
nous coûte 2 milliards d'euros chaque
année
et bien moi je peux vous dire que dans
cette politique migratoire qui nous
coûtent très cher à notre pays vous
trouver de quoi répondre à la
préoccupation de nos retraités
l'enchère la politique migratoire bon de
manière moins coûteuses et qu il ne ce
qu'il ne maltraite pas comme ça nos
retraités ce que vous avez l'interview
fectivement gérald darmanin au journal
de dimanche sous les yeux hier il disait
dans cette interview qu'il était
favorable à une baisse de l'impôt sur le
revenu pour la classe moyenne alors que
laurent wauquiez réclamait une baisse de
10% de l'impôt sur le revenu vous êtes
sur la même nicole gouvernement mais
tant mieux j'attends j'attends de voir
parce que nous voilà des mois que nous
réclamons cette baisse d'impôt sur le
revenu mais encore une fois nous nous
sommes logique c'est à dire qu'on ne
peut pas promettre de baisses d'impôt
sur le revenu sur une baisse pas les
dépenses publiques hors moralité quand
je lis cette interview
y'a pas une piste de réduction des
dépenses publiques il y a des promesses
des miroirs aux alouettes
quand on nous dit encore une fois que la
taxe d'habitation va être supprimé pour
tous
mais encore une fois quand vous regardez
des fiancés en 2022
donc au moment où il y aura les
élections présidentielles dont qu'il
reporte il reporte il reporte mais le
fait aujourd'hui ce que vous partagez de
d d d action pour leur pouvoir d'achat
ça devrait plus tarder puisque vous
partager les positions du gouvernement
sur l'isf et l'impôt sur le revenu
est-ce qu'il n'est pas temps de sortir
des postures sectaire et de tendre la
main à edouard philippe
nous nous n'avons pas cessé peu de temps
dans la main à edouard philippe appui de
faire des propositions d'un goûter notre
notre position elle est toujours
constructives
nous ne faisons pas une opposition de
blocage nous avons fait à chaque fois
des propositions
nous avons d'ailleurs alerté le
gouvernement
quand edouard philippe a pris cette
mesure assez stupide de vouloir mettre
cette ce niveau de 80 kilomètres heure
partout en france sur nos routes
nationales qu'il fallait adapter cette
limitation de vitesse à des secteurs
accidentogènes et par département
nous avions alerté que ça allait
provoquer de la colère nous avons alerté
sur la hausse des taxes nous avons
demandé cette suppression des taxes
nous avons alerté aussi quand le
gouvernement a choisi de désindexer les
retraites de l'inflation nous avons
alerté à chaque fois on se trouve face à
un mur la réalité c'est que nous sommes
dans un dans une mode de gouvernance
verticale sectaire et qui n'entend pas
et tu n'entends rien les responsables
position d'ailleurs les postures secteur
scellement employés par laurent wauquiez
lui-même dans le journal du dimanche je
tends la main au premier ministre
travaille ont ensemble sortons des
postures sectaire êtes vous prête vous à
tendre la main à bruno le maire à gérald
darmanin et nos propositions sont une
main tendue depuis le départ nous
n'avons fait que ça que tendent la main
et on retrouve quoi en face une porte
fermée
quand il fait des propositions sur sur
le rsa en contrepartie de temps de
travail
est ce que vous croyez qu'il a obtenue
pour l'instant une expérimentation dans
sa région
notre président laurent wauquiez pour
l'instant à rien donc en fait c'est ça
la réalité c'est que il fonde et des
centaines d'heures de débats partout en
france travaillent qu'ils auraient dû
faire avant les élections
présidentielles mais en même temps on
voit bien qu'ils sont sourds aux
revendications les plus essentiels
gérable pour nos retraités comme
j'ajoute pardon de le dire mais non
famille parce qu'il faut ré indexer
aussi les allocations familiales
il faut relever le plafond du quotient
familial la natalité depuis deux ans
maintenant est en baisse on n'avait
jamais vu ça en france
nous quand nous étions au pouvoir nous
avons toujours préservé et les retraités
et les familles et les classes moyennes
aujourd'hui les cibles de ce
gouvernement ce sont les retraités les
familles et les classes moyennes
et cette politique a été menée depuis
deux ans et une politique pour les très
riches nous n'en voulons pas gérald
darmanin bruno le maire edouard philippe
longtemps milité dans le même parti que
vous ça ne vous fait pas plaisir que vos
frères d'armes soit aux postes clés du
gouvernement
pardon ne l'appelez pas des ne les
appelez pas des frères d'armes quand
vous voyez bruno le maire
fait le contraire de ce qu'il a plaidé
pendant un an et demi de campagne pour
la primaire des élections de la droite
puisqu'il était favorable à la baisse de
la cg voilà voilà que ministre il met en
oeuvre la hausse de la csg bon chacun
fait ce qu'il veut dans la vie moi je
suis toujours fidèle à mes convictions
on a dit mme morano vous reprochez à
gérald darmanin bruno le maire d'avoir
changé de camp mais ils ne sont pas les
seuls n'ai pas l'impression que nicolas
sarkozy a lui aussi changé de camp pas
du tout alors il faut bien comprendre
qui a le nicolas sarkozy qui respecte sa
fonction institutionnelle c'est à dire
celle d'ancien chef de l'état fidèle à
ses valeurs de deux participent à des
commémorations pour les anciens
combattants avec emmanuel macron il n'a
jamais un mot aimable pour laurent
wauquiez à mai mois des européennes ne
vous inquiétez pas il ya d'abord ce rôle
institutionnel d'ancien président de la
république et il ya aussi ce que pense
nicolas sarkozy et cette fidélité qui
l'a sa famille politique mais il ne
l'affichent pas il s'affiche il était la
semaine dernière avec des parlementaires
de notre famille politique à
l'invitation de d'eric ciotti
ils ont beaucoup échangé je fais partie
de ceux qui le voient aussi très
régulièrement
il s'est exprimé lui-même lorsqu'il y a
eu sur la place de la république la
manifestation contre l'antisémitisme en
disant qu'il n'y avait dans ce pays plus
d'autorité et qu'il réclamait un retour
à l'autorité ne vous inquiétez pas
nicolas sarkozy ne se trompera pas deux
familles et politique
le 26 mai prochain et je pense que d'ici
là il nous donnera évidemment des signes
et des signaux français sur cinq objets
qui le qu'ils comptent soutenir au cours
de ces élections petit appel pour finir
merci made in man and merci à vous
[Musique]